people like Elon Musk are saying that
global warming is an issue but
population collapses worse population
collapse is a very unique type of
existential risk because it doesn't
Galvanize any kind of response and it's
basically unforeseeable until the point
at which it's too late the problem that
we have at the moment with the
population collapse is that we are below
replacement rate you have to have more
children coming out of each couple than
couples that are dying which means that
you need 2.1 children for every couple
we do not have anywhere near that it's
like 1.4 in the US it's the same in the
UK fewer people means fewer people to
make fewer people and that will just
continue and continue if I say
population collapse is something that
you should be concerned about one of the
most common rebuttals to that is good
we're killing the planet humans are a
Scourge on the earth I don't think that
humans are inherently broken and we need
to be gotten rid of as quickly as
possible to save this precious fragile
Planet climate related deaths have gone
down 50 times over the last 100 years as
the climate's supposedly been getting
worse yes the climate is something that
we need to be concerned about too but
climate Mastery is something that humans
have got